it's a two-way thing so if I'm if I'm
it's 50 50 and then you're both on the
same page that's different of course
I'm not gonna do the most and you're
doing the lead okay so I have a question
do you when you go and date two pays
he does but I will pay I can pay no I
didn't say you can pay I said who pays
the guy will okay so why does he have to
invest in you before he's before you
slept but can I tell you something yes
no no no like we have to think about
this why does he have to invest in you
before you've slept with him but I've
done that before to men I've paid on
first dates
I'm talking about what you have done I'm
talking about what typically happens
you're a pretty girl I know these I know
these men pay for you I feel like men I
feel like men are in
um a stereotypical mindset where they
feel like they're the big they're the
big man they have to be responsible for
paying for first date and stuff like
that so I feel like that's why they do
automatically
traditional men are more you you're
right men are in more traditional roles
than women so it's like the men are
coming to you in a traditional role
they're taking you on a date they're
paying but you're you're saying I can't
be a traditional woman for him I can't
give him wifely duties when off the bat
before he even knows if he's gonna get
sex
hold on hold on let me just uh show of
hands here it's 200 pounds uh nothing to
you guys so raise your hand of 200
pounds if the investment goes right it's
great if it doesn't go right okay okay
if one is 200 pounds of nothing so none
of these men are men
[Music]
that can teach me because I want to be
in that place too so and you're willing
to show with nothing no I listen like I
said 200 pounds ain't nothing to a man
you could show him everything and he
would just and he could possibly not be
serious with you and be speaking to
another girl or sleeping with someone
else and that's the that's the only
reason
no until I know that you're serious I
will give I can get I can surrender to
you you're not even respecting a man's
pocket on the first day like I said 200
pounds is nothing you don't respect the
money because you just said it's nothing
because you're looking at it unless he
States he's not able to afford to go on
a date or whatever
you know no man is gonna stay anything
man could have his last 200 pounds bro
you don't date when you're broke
so you can't say that
and then when all of these guys said no
that is something to me you shat on them
you said you said they're not a high
enough caliber of man but I'm saying
from my experience
um they people have paid and I've been
on dates and I've never spoke to a
person again often they spent a lot of
money you know what I mean you're not
valuing their time and money because you
think that every single one of them
that's spending that money whether it's
a hundred pound or 200 pounds you think
all of them have got it there's some man
that probably have taken you out on date
and as they lost probably but I would
never know exactly so then but you're
still not respecting their money I I
don't think about it like that exactly
because you're so you're still saying
that you you can't give them too much
but they're spending 200 pounds on you
on a first date I don't think the way
guys go on they act like money's nothing
to them and they and they're you know
what I mean so why would I would be so
conscious like unless I love you and I
know about your financial situation
you'll be completely okay but this is
the thing you're just not appreciative
because you're saying no you're not I'm
listening to you speak does she come off
appreciative to anyone no no I'm not a
grateful person okay but I'm listening
to you speak if I liked a guy and I
spoke to one level and he came to me and
said I can't even afford to take you out
in a certain place I would not have a
problem with that believe me you just
you just said it ain't nothing to a man
I went out there
right but I said when all the guys in
here said no that is something to me you
said they are not the caliber of man you
insulted them no not right that's not
really so I said broke men don't date
okay so a man's broke if he doesn't want
to spend 200 pounds again I'm from I'm
from a one percent like top earning
family my like broke men can just not
want to spend 200 pounds on someone they
don't know they didn't yeah but I didn't
ask for it's not about that you know
what if a man really likes you and he's
into you he will spend his last 200
pounds without you knowing I wouldn't
have known that yeah
they go on like oh like so but it's not
like a man's going on like anything
man's is not going we're not going to
openly say oh we're going to the dinner
table the bill comes like oh you know I
can't afford this but someone I've never
been in the situation yeah you're never
gonna be that I've never been so I can't
relate
royal royal you're never going to be in
that situation where a man's going to be
on the table I've had one guy say to me
that like go for coffee and you know
he's he I think he's I think he was
testing me but I was fine with that
because I actually liked him like it's
not an issue
no he never but he said that you know
I'm not in a great position right now
and that's fine because I knew he was
intelligent and I knew that he was
someone I could build with because he's
very smart he just wasn't in the right
place at the time no I didn't have an
issue that unfortunately it didn't work
out why did it work out well he's he's
Muslim bro it's not about money like I
I'm not a shallow person so please let's
not do that
we're just repeating back what you're
saying but I'm speaking from my own
experience so far I can't say anything
else but whatever there could have been
at least two I've never had a man that's
that's not been able to pay for
something that he's I'm aware of and he
has I've never had that that you're
aware of there could have been at least
one man that took you on that date that
was the last time probably yeah and I
would never have knew so and I'm
concerned
I do respect that but I think if you
think broke men shouldn't say then
should or then should fat women not date
I just don't know if we have the same
energy no do you know what it is I feel
like beat is in the eye of the beholder
so um
he's in the eye of the beholder period
so there's a guy that might not wait
money isn't it money is in the eye of
the beholder
um listen money money is in the eyes
listen if if you have if your mentality
is above average and you're broke I [__]
with you because I know you got
potential and that we can build together
we can be powerful Fitness potential
it's money later like that's all it is
credentials money later it's more about
that okay okay if you meet bro if you
meet Brokey at 25 and you're with him
for five years he's still broke he
unemployed what you're saying say that
again sorry broke you mean a Brokey guy
25 and he's unemployed and now they're
now um he's 30. um you're still with him
he's unemployed are you staying or going
uh no because you're not pushing me to
my limit no I wouldn't what five you
wouldn't ride up five years if he is
unemployed and broke for five years and
doesn't want to make a move how long
does it take to create a proper business
and be successful in life
not doing nothing
like don't let it okay I forgot it was
unemployed for five years
I'm with you but my my point is you're
you're lying like it's lying yeah you're
just lying because you're like oh if he
has the right mentality I don't care
about money okay but I said like all the
ambition translates to is money later so
when women say oh I don't care about
money yes it does because because women
women do leave if the men don't make
enough money if women outer in the men
they leave but I feel like the average
woman will leave but you are the average
woman I mean the average mindset woman
the average mindset
I definitely don't you definitely you
just said that and everyone tells me I
don't I'm Different
I promise you okay what makes you
different because I I'm just I feel like
I'm very deep and um I've just learned
I've really taken that time out to study
life and to understand how life is I'm
32 now okay eight last month so I feel
like I've taken time out from in to go
inwards and to learn about life and to
just you know be more not logical but be
more um on point I don't know how to
explain it but I don't think my mindset
is average I don't think I will ever be
average and I really believe in myself
okay you're 100 average you're a
comedian no she's a comedian though no
no no look at me look in the dance
series
and that's not an insult
I don't think
I'm telling you I've met women with a
top 10 20. do you know how many women I
speak to hundreds hundreds and I'm
saying like I've met women with the top
ten twenty percent Minds I'm not saying
it's horrible but I'm saying an average
chick when it comes to mindset do you
know what I think I just like I don't I
think money's not I don't I don't think
money is important so it's nothing to me
but see you've contradicted yourself
like 20 times in this conversation it's
very chaotic to like speak to you like
it's very chaotic because I don't really
understand what you're saying okay
because in one hand you kind of we're
speaking down to the men in the room
because they don't want to spend 200
pounds on a date then you're saying
money is nothing do you see how that's
confusing nothing so paying 200 pounds
what is that that I don't that's fine
okay it's not it's nice
and I do but it's not it's not I don't
think about it because it's money's
money it just is what it is because
that's what I mean okay okay
I understand
I understand what you're saying I just
don't think you understand how it sounds
and it sounds really unappreciative and
then it is what it is
I can't change my opinion it is because
you spent 200 pounds every night on
dinner on yourself me I spend a lot of
money not every night no no I can't why
because that's irresponsible
I've had a long-term relationship where
we live together but I've never relied
on a man for anything in my whole entire
life so so it connects your question
okay so all right you've you've never
been proposed to not really not like
that no okay okay so if you were if you
had this amazing mindset you're 32 you
have kids no okay so do you know what
your chance is below 50 of having a
child possibly but if you're if you're
single at 30 your chance is like 40 of
having a kid so you're more likely to
never have children 30 and at 32 that
means you're three years away from
geriatric pregnancy wow like so that
means if you're single today you got to
find a guy in three years to agree to
marry you
um and agree to get in a long-term
relationship marry you and then have a
kid or just get pregnant so so the odd
so physically right right statistically
okay okay okay
so so and based off of like the so the
last you've been dating since what
you're 18 no no well yeah okay so so 10
12 to 14 years you've been unsuccessful
well
right yeah so if you're single right and
I'm not claiming to be the all like I
know everything but I'm saying how how
can you say you're in the top like you
have this amazing mindset if no men have
picked your mindset and it's not looks
you're pretty my mindset changed at 20
at age 28 so before that I was a
different person four years ago okay so
you've got four years to try out this
mindset
and okay I've been going free stuff okay
so and you've been acute you've been
going through things so you've been
accumulating relationship kind of
whatever where you were problematic
okay okay is this
you're in the danger zone
can I just say it wouldn't take three
months to come to a decision on this one
and you're so lovely honestly you have
so much going for you I really like you
thank you don't say things like that
keep it for yourself I'm playing around
though
I don't think you understand okay okay
how is a husband gonna hear that yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible